was the only french president
in modern history to stand trial for
corruption charges and he's now become
the only
ex-french president to be found guilty
of
trying to bribe a judge and influence
peddling and the allegations against him
brought by uh french prosecutors were
that he tried
to offer a top judge top job to a french
magistrate
in return for confidential information
about an inquiry into allegations that
he had received money
from the l'oreal heiress liliane
betancourt
now he protested his innocence he said
he was the victim of a witch hunt by
prosecutors who he said had overreached
their remit but he wasn't able to
convince the judges or neither were his
lawyers and he's been
sentenced to three years now two years
of that sentence are suspended
so he doesn't need to serve those the
last year he would have had to spend in
jail but he's been told he can
serve that sentence that year-long
sentence at home as long as he wears an
electronic
uh bracelet he has 10 days in which to
appeal if he fails that then um he will
be
uh suffering the notoriety of being the
only
ex-french president to stand trial and
be convicted of corruption charges
his predecessor jacques chirac did stand
tron and was convicted
of allegations that he misused public
money
as the mayor of paris but sarkozy
is facing this different charges and
that different kind of infamy
later in the month he also faces along
with a number of others another trial to
do with allegations that uh
he misused money uh illegal campaign
finance allegations
to do with the 2012 election so his
legal troubles
aren't over yet he has 10 days in which
to appeal but either way that turns out
he
still faces another trial and the infamy
of whatever that might bring him